现在真的是特别时候我们普通人床业的时代
历史上就没有比现在更是和床业的时代了
从每次这么说的时候都会被别人怀疑是骗子
时代总会给我们一些机会
然后当一个机会出现的时候很多人是看不懂 看不见
甚至怀疑的
然后过了几年以后突然想明白了
然后又来不及了
甚至还有一些人是都已经出现了好重时间了
然后再看还是看明白
现在就是这样一个情况
两年前我和吴晓波频道聊过这个话题 所以我决定再聊一下
但是我不准备吸收 因为说多了一块挺麻烦的
真正想做设认他会认真的理解我说的
后面说的每个话
想到什么说什么 各位好 来开始
对兄弟非常眼睛
非常眼睛 你去想
你现在有没有那么一个你特别想解决的
然后一直没有解决 都很麻烦很难受
但你愿意
花钱解决的 你别玩话多少钱吧
反正我就是有这么一个
事 我愿意花钱去解决
有没有这么一个事 这第一个
好 然后不准备眼睛
如果失面上正好让你看到
有一个解决方可以解军大家的问题
而且这个人你不要信任 值得信任
讲解还是合适
这个事是不是有可能做成交了
好 现在我们来看一下 做点生意的
创业的 两个基本要素是什么
第一个基本要素就是
你有别人需要的东西
第二个部分是 你是值得信任的 而且讲解不要合适 对吧
然后我们先说 第一个问题
你怎么知道别人需要什么
我们
联系的世界和政治世界是有一个偏差的
就是如果你在以前的范围内 你会发现你
没有什么东西是别人需要的 你们有说我以前是个程序员
我问方面是你们需要做什么事不需要
你们需要解成英文不需要
但是后来有一次我去香港
然后参加一次加活动
然后参加活动的话就我一个是程序员
然后都是商人
然后有很多香港还有很多工作的什么
然后当然他们遇到一个问题
然后我快速度很多的人就通过程序把它解决的
就在他们言里我是一个偷偽牛的人
然后就觉得好奇怪 就是在我原来那个程序的权子里面
我会在那种一些是
不值钱的
但是换了一个权子
就很值钱 一下子就打通了我的认读而卖
所以各位你千万不要认为你掌握的一些知识掌握的经验
然后你用身边的人去评价说这个东西行不行
别人 别人行不行
但是如果你把它放到后来往上
你身边的人不小 不代表别人不需要
对吗
但是你怎么知道别人需要还是不需要的
我觉得这个话题上面说是定位的问题
我前两天先下活动的时候有老婆就问我说胡子哥怎么定位
然后一开始怎么定位
我说你一开始定位这就是一个黄言
因为你一开始去定位就相当于我现在就知道用户需要什么然后我做什么
但是知识的情况是什么
知识的情况我刚才说了你唯一的世界和政治界是有一个偏差的
所以你需要不断的厂势不断的厂势不断的厂势
而这个时候
然后我经常有犯罪的那才是
人们需要同时你也想做你也喜欢
那个就是你的定位
所以各位我们通过这儿你去理解一下自媒体是什么
你不是通过自媒体赚钱
你是什么呢 你是把你过去的
知识和经验分享出去
然后发现没人感兴趣
怕死
再分享一个
没人感兴趣
怕死
然后你又分享了一个好多人感兴趣
同时你也想做那么那个就是你的定位
那个就是你生活来源什么意思
就是你擅长的东西你的经验对别人是有帮助
恰好几个别人的问题这是不是就工区关系呀
对吧好 那第二个问题怎么让别人
信任你
一个最眼睛的方法就是是用装如果你的东西特别好的话你过怕别人是用
好东西拿这个人分享呗
尤其到你的成本并不高的时候
还要一个更决的
就是当你迷人飞的东西批评收费的东西还要好的时候
你就自然而然获得其人
同时你会发现
你会获得大家那一会
各位看过过去的视频
你会发现我给大家讲的很多迷人飞的方法
平理市面上化几千块钱上的口还好
自然而然就成交啊
所以跟你想过这样
你有你的东西有一个别人需要的东西
同时你获得到别人的信任
而且你家家还合适
这个钱就获该你赚了
所以你赚不到钱大概是一下几个第一个
你
没有别人需要的东西
或者你没有找到就是你的经验
你的能力和别人需要像批配的
那个那个底下怎么知道
这个地方
第二个就是你没有获得别人的信任
怎么获得
没有别人需要的东西
可以有
没有用户
可以有用户